Nicole Kidman Nicole Kidman's my god how
hot she was I read she's still hot she's
in big little lies she's so sexy in that
still for like a 73 year old lady you
know in Hollywood years dude yeah we
could probably break it down actually if
they believed we looked back over the
course of all the different you know
phases of Hollywood you can cut
calculate how much one mirrors to
actress which is sad what is happening
reject nation it's Greg here and I'm
John so we're gonna watch today from
honest trailers as I specifically
contacted screen junkies I said Dan
Spencer Joe Roth and everyone who
doesn't even work on the honest trailers
bits y'all need to do one for Batman
Forever because Justice League is coming
out yeah so I credit myself for this
because I'm the only one who tweeted
them like when you see that opening
scroll when they it's only gonna be my
Twitter account yeah it is Chris named
between five times let's stick it on his
trailer for Beth to me and forever it
stars my favorite actor from NCIS early
interested oh yeah New Orleans a little
Cool J yeah which you know that was a
missed opportunity not having him in
this movie
sorry thanks
what
[Music]
manipulated who a producer Tim Burton
Hanks when director Joel Schumacher only
the worst movie I've seen 30 times after
human cure song Tim Burton made back
into the mainstream put too much kinky
stuff in the sequel to sell kids toys
winter brothers special Schumacher as
the provider director to push the
franchise my family but hey we get no
one take it away Joe yeah I'll get
dragged through oh man meet Belle
Kilmer's unique take on bad bets she's
not weird like heatman charming like
loony intimidating my bail swole like
athletic or emotional like a human but
he does contribute one major unique
trait to the Batman legacy his belt is
always open
it's true
[Music]
let's do it buds I guess that's one way
to get you I've got so annoying but
there's also the ones he wearing Riddler
Jim Carrey at the height of his powers
brings the same manic energy he brings
to his other roles okay while Tommy Lee
Jones makes the horrible choice to bring
the same manic energy as Jim Carrey
watch these two actors try to one-up
each other on camera while the real
drama was apparently go behind the
scenes and hugged me and said this
greatest danger yet the only thing that
could actually stop it for good my
therapist dr. chase meridian takes her
place alongside the veil as the latest
bad girl friend you'll never hear from
again
she's got guys shows rings and she's not
using either of them because all she
does is perv out on the stranger in a
rubber suit you are interesting well I
wish I could say that my interest in
yours god I forgot hot cheese Batman
[Music]
experience the family grow bigger with
Chris of darkness Robin who's lame
origin story of the Robin a would
fluently around it's still better than
the Dark Knight Rises actor it was best
to play a cool t-90s cool guy arrayed on
something no one will ever make cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
suit
Akiva Goldsman career and cut out the
insane zip line with a joint but why dad
man that was today by hanging on to his
three redeeming qualities the thumbs up
give a big seal saw the fact that no
matter what you have to say it's not as
bad story
hey let you go starburst didn't sign up
for this the world's craziest laser tag
arena
yeah guy two paces lair only works if
he's facing one direction there to
rearrange the furniture when he turns
around breathe sunflower 3 to the right
4 to the left
rainbow 450 Ivan strange thanks for 30
minutes soup is just boneless cereal I
think that the Twilight Saga are the
most amazing beautiful movies ever made
and I would very much like to marry
Edward Cullen Wow Wow gosh you know the
big difference yes I agree it is
technically not worse than Batman and
Robin however I could watch Batman and
Robin more because Batman and Robin is
so awful that it's kind of enjoyable
yeah this one is just annoying I can't
stand it I can't I can barely sit
through it well in the twist of making
two-face also just manic and and loud
and obnoxious and you have Jim Carrey
with his like up to 11 energy just yeah
that's a headache it's like it's like a
game of tops it's really annoying yeah I
think it had to do with I heard the
whole interview where Jim Carrey was
talking about how Tommy Lee Jones don't
like him I think it had something to do
with how Jim Carrey
you know like Tommy Lee Jones is really
serious actor and Jim Carrey's becoming
famous are playing this guy all sorts of
big expression and I believe they had a
movie come out I forgot which one that
where Jim Carrey is opened up a number
one and like made a crap ton of money
and tell me Lee Jones flopped that
weekend because it was competing with
Jim Carrey's movie I wonder if Tommy Lee
Jones was doing that who compete with
Jim Carrey or was mocking the material
or like knew what he was involved I was
ridiculous it was so annoying and an
insult to who to faces yes it's not like
yeah Cole Kimmy
I forgot how sexy she was I prefer her
with an American accent I'm not a big
fan of her Australian voice I guess I
get what you're what you're good I am
for whatever reason so one time raiding
the coal ship one time that an
Australian accent somehow hurt val
kilmer like i used to really like that I
used to think val kilmer was so cool too
pretty yeah and he just he doesn't leave
an impression on you in this movie
I barely remember any of his moments
like mostly I remember Chris O'Donnell
cuz I remember thinking he was charming
and charismatic as again I thought he
was so cool yeah he wanted to be he was
made for us yeah yeah movie was made for
us not made to rewatch when you're older
yeah Jim Carrey what's weird is even
though he's pretty annoying in this film
to me - he's arguably the best one out
of this film he is being the Riddler his
be Jim Carrey but every interpretation
I've seen of the Riddler is at least
pretty much on par with who this guy is
yeah yeah that makes sense he seems like
he's the most on pitch yeah everybody
and there's a sort of like force of
nature zaniness that he has that kind of
sells it anyway the look of these movies
when Joel Schumacher came in and they
became a lot more neon and a lot more
crazy and a visual style I don't
actually hate that sort of like
live-action comic book cartoon thing I
think is an alright idea I just don't
think these movies execute very well or
Tim Burton's felt like comic books
adaptations this feels like cartoons
yeah yeah that's the major difference
yeah with it it's like wow they're both
arguably cartoons one is strikingly cool
is annoying and bombastic which is funny
because the the original Batman movie I
actually went to a screening once where
they they talked a lot about how that
movie got made and what it meant for the
legitimacy of comics because there were
like people at like Indiana University
and stuff like that working to
legitimize comics in various ways and
yet and like teach courses and stuff
like that and they were involved with
the making of Batman and one of their
points was like we were showing that
this isn't just kid stuff and the first
Batman movie revell you know helped to
revolutionize the superhero genre
and open up a lot of doors and then for
the third and fourth sequel we just go
right back to kids ville that's why I
don't agree with I think that Batman is
meant for kids only specifically yeah I
think that's the one thing Jill
Schumacher got right is that Batman saw
for adults it's not for adults Batman
it's for little kids
and according Joel Schumacher it's meant
for twisted little kids yeah with
deranged sense of humor and children
with a TD or ADHD struggles who also are
into goth the goth black light pains and
end up being loud yeah I think Joel
Schumacher's intention was correct it's
just the execution because of you know
what the studio wanted oh yeah nothing
all right guys well screen junkies great
job on this video my friends John Bailey
great job on the voice-over work once
more John Bale is a good friend of ours
you can subscribe you the real rejects
click that notification bell please
follow us on social media